i
[Música]
y
colombia fue el primer país de américa
latina una región eminentemente
conservadora y católica en derribar el
tabú de la auto nacio en 1997 la corte
constitucional despenalizó el derecho a
morir dignamente cuando el paciente
sufre una enfermedad terminal sin
embargo a pesar de que es un derecho
existe una serie de trabas para acceder
a la muerte digna desde 1997 12
proyectos de ley han circulado en el
congreso buscando reglamentar de forma
específica la auto nash ya todavía sin
éxito el más reciente debate se inició
en septiembre de 2020 pero no se han
derribado las muchas barreras para su
aplicación que en muchos casos vienen
dadas por el desconocimiento de la norma
de quienes prestan el servicio de salud
los críticos también denuncian que las
clínicas de corte religioso dilatan las
solicitudes una situación agravada en
las zonas rurales del país en colombia
se han practicado 194 eutanasia sin
mayores de edad entre 2015 y 2020 según
autoridades pero todavía existe un limbo
jurídico en torno a este derecho en el
país pionero
[Música]
amo la vida pero quiero vivir dignamente
con estas palabras cecilia geither una
mujer chilena que sufre cáncer de mama
lupus y otras complicaciones derivadas
de su larga enfermedad se convierte en
el último rostro visible a menudo un
rostro de mujer es solicitar
públicamente en chile- el derecho a
morir dignamente haider ha llevado su
caso a los tribunales chilenos y ya ha
ganado su primera batalla cuando un
tribunal acogió su recurso a no ser
trasladada del hospital donde se
encuentra ingresada por su enfermedad
hasta su casa y de donde recibe
constantes transfusiones de sangre que
son cada vez más frecuentes para que
pueda mantenerse con vida mientras un
proyecto de ley avanza en el congreso
fue aprobado en la cámara de diputados
en diciembre pasado está siendo revisado
por una comisión de salud y podría ser
votado en el senado en los próximos
meses veremos así si en un país
profundamente conservador como el chile
puede abrirse paso el derecho a una
muerte digna para todos
[Música]
el congreso de perú se alista debatirá
en las próximas semanas un proyecto de
ley de legalización de la eutanasia en
este país es catalogada como delito de
homicidio y puede ser castigada hasta
con tres años de cárcel
la propuesta busca regular el derecho
que le asiste un paciente de pedir ayuda
médica para poner fin a su vida en el
ejercicio de derechos fundamentales como
son la autonomía y la dignidad humana se
propone que la eutanasia sea permitida
en los casos de pacientes que sufren de
enfermedades incurables en fase terminal
o degenerativas el tema ha creado un
conflicto al interior del gobierno del
presidente francisco sagasti que
mantiene una doble postura sobre su
legalización mientras el ministro de
justicia eduardo vega apoya la demanda
de una ciudadana que pide a una corre
que no se criminalice a la eutanasia
los abogados del ministerio de justicia
se oponen por su parte el colegio médico
señala que no está a favor de la
eutanasia pero sí de la muerte digna a
través de los cuidados paliativos que
alivian al paciente hasta su muerte
biológica
[Música]